bonjour à tous je vous propose cet été
de découvrir près de chez vous un lieu
dédié aux loisirs entre amis ou en
famille direction la base de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines où y vivrez
des moments d'évasion et de détente y en
a pour tous les goûts voile équitation
réserve naturelle parcours dans les
branches des commençons tout de suite
avec l'une des activités phares et syna
vague keller
quoi de mieux qu'une fissiles et même
une piscine à vagues pour profiter de
l'été retrouvons tout de suite son
responsable guillaume rythme pour se
rafraîchir que de se rendre à la piscine
à vagues qui est ouverte tout l'été je
crois la piscine à vagues est ouvert
tout l'été exactement jusqu'au 31 août 7
jours sur 7 du lundi au vendredi de 12h
à 19h le samedi de 13 heures à 19 heures
avec une possibilité de prolonger
jusqu'à 20h à en fonction de la météo et
enfin le dimanche et les jours fériés de
11 heures à 20 heures tout autour de la
piscine on a également un grand espace
d'herbe est ce qu'on peut venir pique
en famille oui effectivement
c'est un espace de trois hectares de
plage verte où on peut venir en famille
entre amis pouvoir qui cliquaient
profiter de ces espaces pour se détendre
on a également un solarium ou des
chaises longues sont à disposition
gratuitement pour pouvoir venir se
détendre et un livre profiter de cette
belle vue qui est la piscine avec de
saint quentin en yvelines et a rappelé
nous justement comment fonctionne fils
malade il y à une série de vagues de 10
minutes toutes les heures et donc en
amont il ya bien une annonce pour
prévenir l'arrivée de ces vagues et
garantir des consignes de sécurité réuni
des maîtres nageurs qui sont présents
donc tout l'été de trois maîtres nageurs
jusqu'à cette même nageur en fonction de
l'affluence du public
est-ce qu'on peut jouer au ballon des
choses comme ça dans l'eau effectivement
c'est autorisé bien sûr c'est sans
pouvoir gêner le public qui voudraient
profiter de l'espace aquatique pour
nager de préférence avec des balles en
plastique le bassin représente à peu
près combien de 1700 mètres carrés
d'espacé de bassin avec une petite
pataugeoire pour les enfants
ne sachant pas nager ou bien sûr qu'ils
doivent rester sous la surveillance de
leurs parents
même si les sauveteurs aquatiques sont
là pour gérer la sûreté et la
surveillance du bassin faut pas que ça
se soustraire à la surveillance des
parents aux enfants
et puis on peut rappeler que tout autour
de la piscine également différentes
activités sont mis en place des
activités gratuites
oui des activités gratuites tout l'été
pour l'ensemble des usagers qui pénètre
dans cet espace de la piscine à vagues
donc sur le terrain de sable de 700 m²
les activités telles que le sambal
activités de hand sur sable du flag
rugby du beach volley ces activités sont
gratuites et facile d'accès juste se
présentait au bungalow à l'entrée de
l'espace de sam donc c'est compris dans
le prix d'entrée de la piscine
oui effectivement au new dawn est une
fourchette de tarifs une fourchette de
tarifs
on va dire que les tarifs vont de 5
euros pour l'état un groupe en semaine
jusqu'à 7 euros 50 pour les tarifs deux
adultes jours fériés dimanche
sur le plan pratique et ce qui est des
kazim des choses comme ça qui sont donc
il n'y a pas classe le casier il ya des
vestiaires pour pouvoir se changer
par contre les usagers doivent garder
toutes leurs affaires avec eux sur le
sable et autres questions pratiques pour
les hommes en l'occurrence est ce qu'il
faut un maillot de bain un tipi cils
parfois réglementée alors au niveau des
tenues de
tenues autorisé pour la baignade le
short de bain au dessus du genou et
toléré a autorisé et ensuite par contre
toute combinaison même les t-shirts
également lorsque on dépasse la zone du
pédiluve on va dire qu'on sorte de la
plage verte un nombre des espaces verts
pour retirer son tee shirt même pour
pouvoir surveiller ses enfants faut être
en tenue de bain qui est autorisé
alors cette année cet été même vous nous
proposez des activités très sportive à
30 et effectivement ça va commencer le
15 juillet avec l'arrivée du judo tour
les acculer une dernière déjà
et donc ils reviennent sur trois jours
pour des initiations et des
démonstrations de champion là sur une
table de judo donc les familles pourront
participer également
oui effectivement c'est destiné à tous
petits et grands et donc y aura des
initiations que vous pourrez apprendre à
faire des ippons ici sera basée la zone
donc le 15 et le 17 au sein de la
piscine à vagues et le 16 au sein du
parc promenade près de centres équestres
juillet donc j'ai d'autres activités ce
parti des nouveautés d'ailleurs ouest a
fait on vient de recevoir notre
structure de football donc le bol j'ai
adoré cette question c'est un grand
filet en fait une grande cage enfilé
avec cinq buts incrusté de chaque côté
et le but c'est de marquer un maximum de
buts ça joue au pied et à la main il ya
un but rouge de ben et john donc je vous
invite à découvrir cette activité
vraiment hyper fun tout l'été c'est
gratuit alors c'est complètement gratuit
et on la propose aussi au sein d'un
dispositif qui s'appelle le village
sportif d'été qui est financé par le
conseil régional d'île de france et qui
nous permet de proposer plus d'une
vingtaine d'activités gratuites vous
pourrez faire de la zumba de la peteca
15 portugal brésil
ces tendances du centre bell et du
handball sur sable du flag rugby la
sarbacane et plein d'autres activités
comme ça tout l'été vous propose
également une innovation balade qui
associe balade énigmes fait nous en
parler tout à fait vous connaissez
peut-être le principe dans paris pour le
coup découvert un arrondissement de
paris via des énigmes donc on a
développé exactement le même concept sur
la base de loisirs donc à vous faites ça
en famille mais aussi une version pour
les groupes et une version pour les
entreprises et en
passer une demi-journée sur la base de
loisirs à résoudre les différentes
énigmes trouver les photos
résoudre des anagrammes etc donc c'est
vraiment très conviviale sa part les
découvrir l'enceinte de la base de
loisirs faut chausser ses baskets alors
c'est une balade de combien de temps de
près il vaut mieux passer une balle de 3
heures donc chaussez vos baskets
prenez plutôt un pantalon même si la
plupart étant ça passerait des sentiers
nous voilà mais en tout cas c'est
vraiment sympa moi je vous en prie
cet été à la base de loisirs vous
pourrez également faire de l'équitation
une somme censée être nous allons
retrouver sa responsable sans traduire
en cendres à cet été vous proposer des
stages des initiations des matelles
dites moi un peu plus alors déjà
principalement les activités auront lieu
sur le mois de juillet donc avec des
baptêmes poney tous les après midi de 14
heures à 18 heures pour des enfants âgés
de 2 jusqu'à 8 10 ans à peu près ça
consiste en quoi un baptême donc là
c'est un petit tour de poney de 10
minutes à peu près durant lequel les
parents tiennent le poney font le tour
avec leurs enfants pour vraiment faire
une première approche du poney donc ça
c'est un lieu tous les jours
après ça on a des stages d'initiation
donc là ça va être pour des enfants à
partir de 4 ans jusqu'à 8 ans et après
ça des plus grands à double poney donc
pareil des stages d'initiation donc on
profite des vacances scolaires en fait
pour faire découvrir un petit peu
l'équitation en vue d'une future
inscription ça évite d'engager les
parents tout de suite dès le mois de
septembre sur une inscription
directement donc il ya ces stages de dix
ans voilà où là les enfants vont
vraiment apprendre à découvrir à brosser
un poney à le sceller sont occupés
vraiment et après apprendre à monter
dessus a dirigé à le faire avancer à
découvrir le trop et c'est à dire quand
même temps donc ça c'est des stages
qu'ont lieu par demi-journée ou par
journée et puis sur un deux trois ou
cinq jours suivant le programme des
stages
voilà donc ça faut appeler pour avoir le
programme des stages et puis après ça on
a des stages de perfectionnement donc
pour nos adhérents pour des gens qui
sont déjà cavaliers à l'extérieur avec
des possibilités de passage d'examens
fédéraux du type du galop 2 3 4 et 5
c'est des stages sur combien de journées
alors c'est pareil c'est assez variable
on va avoir des stages sur une semaine
sur une journée sur plusieurs demi
journées mais sur une semaine
en semaine le week-end voilà donc ça
c'est son choix
voilà c'est assez varié et puis on a des
stages également en soirée donc pour
avoir accès aux adultes qui travaillent
on a des stages de 19h30 à 21h pareil
des stages de perfectionnement ou
d'initiation et vous propose également
en lien avec le village d'été des
balades alors un combat l'eau en lien
est pas en lien avec le village d'été on
a les deux choses c'est à dire qu'on
peut proposer de la promenade aux
particuliers qui voilà donc sur
réservation qui va vouloir venir en
famille ou tout seul ou en couple voilà
venir découvrir la base de loisirs à
cheval et sur tout le mois d'août
effectivement on organise des promenades
en lien avec le village sportif d'été
donc oui ils sont plusieurs activités
dont classé pour des jeunes de 11 à 17
ans où ils vont venir découvrir sur 1h30
2h l'équitation et puis une promenade
dans le parc est ce que dans le cas du
village d'été c'est gratuit ou pas comme
les autres activités qui sont proposées
voilà tout à fait c'est gratuit fins et
financé par la région ile de france mais
pour les jeunes qui vont venir
effectivement c'est une opération
gratuite sur les différentes activités
en lien avec la piscine à vagues et
d'autres actifs oui vous avez chez vous
ici alors chevaux et poneys confondues
on en a une soixantaine puisqu'on a des
shetland pour vraiment pouvoir
accueillir les enfants de 4 ans jusqu'à
8 9 ans on a ensuite des double poney
jusqu'à 13 14 ans et après on passe à
cheval à partir de 14 ans à peu près 14
15 ans on passe à cheval et y compris
pour les adultes
je suppose que vous mettez à disposition
bongo cravache
oui oui tout à fait on fournit le
matériel juste avoir un équipement
vestimentaire on va dire adapté pas
venir en jupe et en tongs
mais après ça on fournit le casque ont
fourni ce dont il a besoin les brosses
et c'est tout le matériel pour pouvoir
monter
et si on prenait à présent un petit peu
de hauteur direction le parcours dans
les arbres
- jean-francois be bonjour vous êtes
responsable branches et loisirs vous
êtes équipé d'un baudrier
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire alors ici on
peut faire des parcours acrobatiques en
hauteur comme on peut le voir ici
du coup avoir quatre parcours avec
baudriller du coup on a du coup un verre
un bleu à rouge et noir c'est en
fonction des niveaux
c'est sa hausse en fonction du niveau en
fonction de l'âge et de la taille voire
deux parcours le vert et le bleu qui
sont destinés à des enfants de 6-12 ans
donc plus d'un mètre dix plus d'un mètre
voilà du coup les parcours rouge et noir
qui sont offerts aux enfants ouvert aux
enfants de plus de 12 ans et du coup à
partir d'un mètre quarante cinq et donc
aux adultes aussi et donc aux adultes
naturellement pas là donc c'est
finalement une activité pour toute la
famille alors c'est tout pour toute la
famille ce qu'on a en plus un petit
parcours qui vit du coup on n'utilise
pas ce billet est ce que tu parcours là
le parcours blanc donc est réservée aux
3 6 ans et celle du coup se pratique au
dessus d'un grand filet en toute
sécurité
alors qu'est ce que viennent chercher
des familles parties dont ici à bail
j'aime chercher surtout du
divertissement un petit peu d'amusement
un petit peu je dirais tu peux me
permettre un petit peu d'excitation
parce que du coup ils sont auteurs une
sensation qu'on n'a pas l'habitude
d'avoir quand on se lance sur une
tyrolienne c'est qu'on jette un peu dans
le vide
voilà donc sa démonstration ou pas il
faut être fou avoir une aptitude
physique alors pas forcément nous en
avons une attitude physique maintenant
c'est vrai quand on a le vertige c'est
pas forcément évident mais au moins
c'est quelque chose qui peut se
combattre si on se donne un petit peu de
motivation ça peut le faire s comment
vous accompagner à lors du sommet non
accompagnés
quand les clients arrivent du coup on
les équipe de bologne et on leur
explique
on leur fait faire un petit parcours
fait ce qu'on vérifie que tout se passe
bien et puis une fois qu'on est sûr que
tout se passe bien du coup on les laisse
partir en autonomie sur les parcours
néanmoins nous l'assurent du coût des
rondes de surveillance en dessous des
parcours et des coûts moindres problèmes
du coup on intervient qu'on est dure en
moyenne un parcours puisque ses
fonctions ses fonctions de 20 minutes
pour le verre 35 minutes pour le pour le
bleu faut compter 1 45 minutes pour le
rouge et environ une heure pour le noir
il faut est équipé comme un tenue
sportswear avec des chaussures plutôt
adéquat et surtout éviter les semelles
de crêpe ce que du coup ça fait mal aux
pieds avec les câbles et pour ceux qui
ont envie de plus de sensations
peut-être extrême le parcours dans les
arbres est aussi disponible de nuit
alors effectivement pour clôturer l'été
du coup 1 le 29 août du coup on a une
date d'à crown heights et donc du coup
ça va se passer de lui donc le principe
est un petit peu le même que journée
sauf que du coup on vient rajouter des
spots fluo dans les arbres des petites
lampes frontales sur le sur le front des
participants et encore c'est différent
les sensations sont vraiment différents
la sensation est complètement différent
parce que de plein jour même quand vous
regardez pas fort quand vous regarder
devant vous un chant qui est
pratiquement à 180 alors que là du coup
être la frontale le chant se réduit en
fait vous ne voyez devant vous plus que
ce que vous avez regardé donc si vous
regardez à droite vous voyez des
feuilles se regarder à gauche
jouer des feuilles soient quelle grande
roue et icap si vous regardez le sol
mouillé tout noir c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est complètement différent
mais ça permet éventuellement à des
personnes qui ont le vertige
du coup d'avoir moins cette sensation de
vide puisque du coup il ne voit plus le
sol général c'est le retour qu'on a
après ça peut être différent d'une
personne rythme et en général c'est le
retour qu'on bon bah alors voilà pour
les sensations fortes et parcours dans
les branches
et
où
après le sport je vous propose une pause
détente au sein de la réserve naturelle
nous allons retrouver s'y référer
bonjour bonjour est animateur qu'est ce
que vous allez proposer
c'était alors cet été on propose une
visite libre en fête mardi 23
plus tôt en soirée étrange et 23 juillet
bien sûr donc il ya un sentier
pédagogique sur la réserve naturelle
pas besoin de réserver en fait vous
venez c'est vraiment une visite libre
par contre il ya un membre de notre
équipe qui est sur le terrain pour
répondre à vos questions aux différentes
questions au niveau du matériel
on vous demande d'amener avec vous une
paire de jumelles
nous on a une longue vue on peut vous
montrer les espèces à travers la longue
vue c'est vraiment extraordinaire parce
qu'elles sont relativement loin une
longue-vue ça rapproche énormément
l'oiseau on peut voir en détail des
oiseaux qu'on voit ces périodes là en
fait c'est un début de migration et on
voit des espèces qu'on ne voit
absolument pas autrement qu'à ces
périodes et c'est une balade avec des
points précis de d'observation oui alors
on a deux observatoires et on à ce point
haut qui domine toute la réserve donc
les observatoires c'est un lieu vraiment
tranquillité où vous pouvez observer
vous pouvez rester de 17h30 à 21h vous
pouvez décider de rester une heure vous
faites exactement ce que vous voulez le
tour de la réserve ça prend environ avec
les observations une bonne heure une
bonne heure et quart mais vous pouvez
profiter en fait de la quiétude
lieu et c'est vraiment magique de
pouvoir observer toute cette nature dans
un milieu quand même relativement
urbanisées tout autour c'est le mardi 23
juillet à partir de 17h entartrage
jusqu'à 21h vous proposer une autre
grande journée la dent canoë
alors là c'est un peu différent
justement on a l'habitude souvent de
découvrir la nature à pied et là on va
être sur les canaux et sur l'eau on a la
chance d'avoir cette immense zone humide
d'île de france et on va découvrir en
fait le côté historique de l'étang est
quand même très important ici en fait
vous serez sur place on sera sur place
on sera avec les personnes là par contre
c'est complètement encadré complètement
guidés par contre il faudra réserver
on ne rentrera pas par contre dans la
réserve naturelle pour la quiétude des
espèces par contre et des milieux aussi
protéger les milieux par contre on
pourra s'en approcher énormément et donc
on a la chance d'être toujours sur des
périodes de migration et on peut avoir
par exemple des espèces qui plonge pas
très loin de nous pour aller pêcher des
poissons et ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose à faire de son appareil photos
aussi
oui on peut plutôt étanche ambitions et
sur l'eau mais oui oui effectivement
et des fois les observations par contre
contrairement à d'autres d'autres
animations qu'on fait ou là on a besoin
de matériels peuvent être tout à fait
proche de vous puisque des fois c'est
qu'il ya quelques mètres du canoë quand
on a beaucoup de chance et donc ça ce
sera le 30 août voilà moments
inoubliables le 30 août à 14h20
s'inquiète 14h30 merci beaucoup sans
merci
aujourd'hui les grecs bonjour vous êtes
responsable du pôle séjour et vous
proposer des séjours plutôt atypique
donc quelque chose d'assez innovant
raconté bah oui tout à fait sur la base
de loisirs on propose des pour les
groupes et les familles des séjours
originaux qu'on sur des lieux voilà un
petit peu hors du commun où on n'a pas
ça effectivement sur l'ensemble de la
région
donc effectivement propose des séjours
sous yourte et sous tipis sur la base de
loisirs des yourtes des tipis qui
s'adresse ou alors acquis et des
familles des amis des petits cdc jours
pour le tout public
donc la semaine on accueille des groupes
des centres de loisirs qui viennent
profiter des vacances un petit peu et
puis sur les week-ends on accueille des
familles qui viennent pour diverses
raisons et occupant familiaux
enterrement de vie de jeune fille vide
garé son mariage dans un espace naturel
et puis t'amuser c'est ça voilà on est
en plein coeur de la base de loisirs à
proximité de l'étang il ya que de la
verdure autour de nous et les familles
voilà se mettre un petit peu ouverts et
profite d'un petit peu d espaces verts
de la base alors sur plan fonctionnel on
a on a un barbecue par exemple on a des
tables de pique nique extérieurs et des
parasols et surtout on a une lourde
cuisine qui permet de vivre complètement
en autonomie de se préparer à manger de
prendre son petit-déjeuner le matin de
se faire son repas le soir il me dit
avec des frigos des fous des plaques à
induction mis à disposition pour qu'un
certain confort voilà les gens font
leurs courses avant viennent avec leurs
sacs de nourriture ils s'installent et
puis voilà on peut très rapidement vivre
facilement le séjour il ya des lidd dans
les yourtes
on amène son hiver on est déjà couché
enfin voila c'est logiquement très
fonctionnel c'est fait pour ça en fait
en ce qui concerne le prix fourchette
indiquée alors oui sur les petites
yourte de deux on est aux alentours de
on est sur 45 euros la nuit pour deux
voilà donc une petite chute de 2 et puis
on a des yourtes de 8
et là on est sur la yourte pour 8
personnes pour une nuit on est à 160
euros
voilà ces prix là comprennent évidemment
l'accès à la cuisine
voilà qui est disponible pour tout ce
qui est censé être un espace un petit
peu collectif pour chaque famille dans
lequel on peut se regrouper ensemble
même si on est deux familles différentes
par exemple on peut très bien cohabiter
dans une yourte cuisiner se faire à
manger chacun dans son coin voilà et ou
alors même tous ensemble est-ce qu'on
peut également profiter des activités
bien sûr on alors on propose
effectivement pour les pour les familles
le week-end la possibilité d'aller
pratiquer des activités autres après sur
la base
voilà sur les yourtes vous êtes sur le
site de la ferme pédagogique par exemple
il est allé chercher ses deux par l'amp
le matin à les acheter des frais oui on
peut aller chercher ces eaux fraîches
chercher son miel si on veut participer
à la traite des chèvres
je pense que ma collègue vous en parlera
plus amplement tout à l'heure mais voilà
il ya des activités de dimanche matin
pour les familles et on découvre par
exemple la fabrication du fromage avec
le avec les chefs donc il ya plein il ya
plein de choses à faire effectivement
lien avec la nature ici
et si on allait vérifier que les eaux
sont bien disponibles à la ferme pour ça
je vous propose de rencontrer
fabienne ducrocq la responsable de la
femme pédagogique savez n'y paraît qu'on
peut venir chercher des oeufs frais à la
ferme
alors oui effectivement on a des yeux
ferait alors pas tous les jours ça
dépend de nos pôles suivants comment
répondre et on a aussi du miel sur la
ferme pédagogique alors du miel des
frais et puis vous proposer des
activités toute l'année mais là le club
spécifiquement pour l'été tous les jours
à 4h30 sauf le week-end y aura un
atelier à l'intention des parents
accompagnés de leurs enfants
donc à partir de 3 ans et ensuite le
jeudi après midi à partir de 14h toutes
les semaines il y aura un atelier
différent donc le programme sera mis en
ligne sur le site internet de la base
est lassé des ateliers plus long qui
dure entre 1h30 et 2h et après on
propose comme toute l'année notre
atelier du dimanche matin sur la traite
de la chèvre à 10h30 ça s'adresse plutôt
oovoo dix enfants partir de quel âge
alors enfants principalement donc les
soins tous les jours à 4h30 à partir de
3 ans les activités du jeudi ce sera
suivant l'activité proposée donc ça
c'est indiqué sur le site à partir de
quel âge on peut le faire en fait
d'accord juste pour nous donner un
aperçu quelles thématiques par exemple
dans ses différents alors on va avoir
plein de choses on va avoir les soins de
la basse-cour on va aussi avoir la
traite des chèvres d'ici début août
on va avoir un atelier sur l'extraction
du miel donc comme on a fait ce week-end
une journée fidélise là ça sera pareil
extraction du miel avec les ruches et
après on va avoir d'autres ateliers aux
affaires du pain du jardin va faire
plein de choses sur la ferme en fête
qu'est ce qui plaît aux enfants ils
viennent ici qu'est ce qui va mal et
séduit bah c'est vraiment le contact
avec l'asie ni les animaux on est au
milieu de la ville et finalement il ya
des animaux de la ferme qu'ils ont
parfois jamais vu et c'est des animaux
qui sont habitués donc de ferme
pédagogique les enfants peuvent les
caresser
si ça leur plaît ils peuvent repartir
avec quelque chose d'aussi alors suivi
l'atelier par exemple pour le pain ils
peuvent repartir avec avec du pain il ya
des ateliers où ils vont fabriquer des
empreintes d'animaux et puis après ils
repartent avec plein de souvenirs plein
la tête en fait
la base de loisirs se sont également des
activités sur l'eau pour sa rendez vous
à l'école de voile aujourd'hui guichou
bonjour cette responsable de l'école de
voile donc à la base de loisirs vous
organisés cet été des stages pour les
jeunes
expliquez-nous comment ça va se passer
alors tout l'été chaque semaine on
accueille des jeunes entre 7 et 18 ans
pour les stages de voile sont des stages
qui dure une semaine on a la possibilité
les jeunes ont la possibilité de
naviguer le matin ou l'après-midi sur
chaque demi journée ou sur cinq journées
complètes
le matin c'est plus de la planche à
voile et l'après midi du dériveur du
catamaran est ce qu'ils font est déjà un
petit peu amateur ou pas non non pas du
tout on prend des jeunes qui sont en
initiation ou un perfectionnement qui
ont fait des tranches d'âgés on voit là
les moniteurs sont là pour pour leur
apprendre ou les perfectionner sur sur
le support qu'ils ont choisi ce sera en
juillet et en août
chaque semaine du lundi au vendredi tout
le mois de juillet tout le mois d'août
vous proposez également de la location
en fête et de voiliers et de canoë pour
les familles oui toutes les familles qui
souhaitent venir sur la base de loisirs
peuvent venir à l'école de voile louer
des canoës des kayak planche à voile
dériveur ce qu'il faut c'est que pour la
ce qui est voilà avoir une petite
connaissance quand même de la voile pour
le canoë le kayak il n'y a pas de
problème tout le monde peut venir
la seule condition est que les jeunes
sachent nager
voilà donc un minimum de sécurité oui
comme vous tester nos moutons on
interroge les parents et les parents
nous disent ces jeunes soldats jeunes
d'accord donc des jeunes seuls peuvent
partir s'ils sont suffisamment grand ça
reste sous la responsabilité de leurs
parents propose également des stages duo
d'activité qu'est ce que c'est
exactement avec le centre équestre ont
organisé ce stage qu'on appelle et qui
voile une demi-journée donc sur une
semaine aussi une demi-journée en voile
le matin et une demi journée au centre
équestre en équitation pour des jeunes à
partir de 7 ans hélas le le repas du
midi aussi est pris sur place le repas
du midi est aussi pris sur place ou et
je vous en prie
la base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines ouvre ses portes tous les jours
de 7h30 à 22h30 n'oubliez pas qu'il
existe deux entrées celle du côté de
trappes portes du parc et celle du côté
du vélodrome portes de ladite tout ça
pour éviter les engorgements
l'entrée est à 4 euros pour les voitures
et les motos et gratuit pour les piétons
les vélos et les saint quentinois qui se
sont unis au préalable de leur carte
d'entrée qui elle même est à retirer
auprès de leur mairie n'hésitez pas à
vous rendre sur site internet pour
toutes les informations que vous
souhaite un excellent entêté à bientôt